good evening I'd like to thank you all
for coming and before I do anything else
I'd like to model good behavior and take
up my cell phone and turn it off I'm
Curt freudenberg chair of the Department
of classics here at Yale and it's my
great pleasure to welcome all of you
here this evening to the 8th annual
Michael Ivanovich for a stop cept
lecture as I'm sure that all of you know
Michael hristov sep was a giant in the
study of the ancient world who taught as
a Yale sterling professor in ancient
history and classical archaeologic
archaeology from 1925 until his
retirement in 1944 this event comes to
you by way of the generous support of
the Sofia mostov SEF request upon her
passing Sophie Rostov SEF left the
department a generous sum of money that
was to be used in the words of the
indenture with the best judgment of the
Department of classics for the promotion
of research in archaeology and history
and thus was born not just this annual
lecture but a whole set of further
projects and activities in support of
the study of the ancient world at Yale
University the rest' offset fund
supports many good causes both social
and scholarly and these include annual
fellowships for graduate students to
travel to archaeological sites tonight's
lecture is the first and main event in a
two-day rustavi fest I want to alert you
to what else you have to look forward to
immediately following the lecture this
evening there will be a lavish reception
at the royal restaurant and cafe Roy is
located just around the corner at 261
College Street on the first floor of the
old Taft hotel I invite everyone here to
please join us for hors d'oeuvres and
drinks and lively conversation after the
talk and if you don't know how to get to
Roya no worries just join up with
whatever group is heading over that way
after the lecture and you'll be there in
about four to five minutes then tomorrow
at 9am in room 401 of phelps hall that's
Michael hristov SEFs old office
there will be a follow-up symposium
structured around responses to tonight's
lecture those leading the discussion
besides Professor Bruce on himself will
be Brian muse of the University of
Chicago Dorothy Thompson herself a
former Rostov SEF lecture welcome back
Dorothy from the University of Cambridge
and Graham Oliver from Brown University
and there's sure to be lots of local
participation from students and scholars
here at Yale as well so again you're
cordially invited to attend 9am on the
fourth floor of phelps hall and as
always there will be abundant coffee and
refreshments now for just a couple of
words of thanks before I turn this over
to my colleague no lenski first thanks
to all of you for coming out this
evening to students especially both
undergraduate and graduate and yes we do
notice when you come to these things I
saw Daphne where are you okay good we're
watching but in a good way to our
stalwart friends of the classics here at
Yale and there are so many of you here
that I dare not try to name you all also
to Linda Dickey so CA and Tracy finer
are administrative assistants in the
Department of classics who are behind
the planning of all the evenings events
down to the smallest details and to
Professor Joe Manning all that I have
just described to you is happening this
evening and tomorrow because Joe Manning
has spent countless hours of hard work
spread out over many months to make it
happen he's done this many years now and
he does it cheerfully and always with an
eye towards making this the premier
ancient history event in the country
brilliantly done as always Joe we are
all the beneficiaries of your hard work
and now I see the stage to Professor
Knohl Lensky of the Department of
History and classics here al and nor
will give the formal introduction to
tonight speaker
thank you Kirk and thank you once again
to all of you for showing up this
evening and the weather your students or
faculty or distinguished guests and
especially they like to extend a word of
thanks to our distinguished guests to
our speaker this evening a lab vessel
and to the remaining members of the
panel he'll be speaking us tomorrow
morning and I hope you can all perhaps
block out some time in order to attend
at least part of that event where we'll
have for the discussion about the paper
this evening that those speakers will be
Dorothy Thompson Bryan views and Graham
Oliver all of whom are in the audience
this evening I too would like to thank
Joe Manning for his amazing work bring
us together and also freudenberg for the
work that he does as chair to keep
everything running smoothly in the
department's but now to the matter at
hand and that is introducing our speaker
a lamb person who is the Robert Oh
Anderson distinguished service professor
at the University of Chicago a title he
has held since 2014 he has been
professor at the University of Chicago
since 2008 where he served as chair in
the years between 2011 in 2014 prior to
moving to the United States bristle was
on the faculty of the university of
bordeaux for nearly three decades
bristles studied at the University of
Leon and took his doctorate at the
University of France quantavis on salt
he also obtained a degree in social
mathematics and applied computing from
the university of bordeaux he has an
impressively long list of
accomplishments including invited
lectures all over the globe from Los
Angeles to Moscow including several past
visits to Yale as well he's also managed
field projects in the Aegean
particularly in Asia Minor bracelet is
at once an historian and a pig refer a
numismatists and
economist his earliest work focused on
Greek textual sources from which he
moved into epigraphy and following this
the economy with a healthy amount of
anthropology thrown in for good measure
nor has he abandoned former research
fields he passed from one to the next
like some sort of slash and burn
agriculture list on the contrary he
continues an active research program in
all of the mini territories he has
cultivated his lengthy CV reveals that
he's edited or co-edited some six books
he has published or has impressed nearly
100 articles many of them groundbreaking
studies and here I call attention to
exam for example to a 2006 article on
Maui Police adidas in which he showed an
amazing command of epigraphic and other
forms of evidence that allowed him to
prove that prices for oil and grain rose
in response to intense local demand when
the succeeded available supply in the
regional market but that stagnant or
declining prices tend to reflect
patterns in the broader international
market place only has also published in
less than five monographs the first of
these meet a competition was an analysis
of Pindar's seventh olympi ack he then
published Liquide as inscription drop fa
ho tien which offers a catalogue over
200 inscriptions with commentary from
the mediterranean is Mediterranean
island with da Mouse jealousy tml sean's
published in two thousand places on
moved squarely and decisively into the
field of economic history this book as
the title indicates represents a shot
across the bow of Moses Finley's notion
of the consumer city Finley is of course
a towering figure in the history of the
ancient economy who propounded a theory
of economic primitivism a lack of
economic rationalism limited market
regulation by the state cities
interested in production not consumption
non-existent commercial banking thus
lending only for consumption
not for investment and ultimately little
if any real economic growth the souls
book questions all of these notions
using a series of case studies that
provide solid evidence for market
regulation by cities an interest in
promoting and regulating long distance
and local trade on the part of cities
and some measure of economic rationalism
on the part of individuals and even the
state the problem as graceland sees it
is that for all that the Greeks had a
very solid understanding of rational
economic behavior at the level of the
household they never developed a firm
sense of macroeconomics but simply cross
apply their notions of household
management to the palace and interstate
level policeman's masterwork is surely
his at l'économie like to SD CTA
published in two volumes in 2007 and
2008 which survey the Greek economic
history from the 6th to the first
centuries BCE so clearly a monumental
undertaking this book has recently been
translated and updated in an edition
that's just out from Princeton
University Press and I present the copy
that's on Colin and will be sad to learn
I have absconded with from the classics
non-circulating library but I promise
I'll get it back even this evening just
so that you can see what a beautiful
volume that is and perhaps put it on
your Christmas wish list the book steers
something of a middle course in the
modernist primitive asst to bait
pointing out both of the severe
limitations environmental technological
etc on economic growth in the Greek
homeland and the amazingly robust
performance of the Greek economy in the
Classical period during the 5th and 4th
centuries BCE they don't argues the
Greek economy witness growth on the
order of 0 point four percent annually
putting it not far out of line with the
growth rate of early modern economies in
Northern Europe placement is able to
make this and many other convincing
claims in compendium with some 600 pages
of detailed arguments covering all
aspects of the Greek economy from the
environment and landscape to the money
supply and inflation to the credit
markets and trade regulation alone as a
survey of the empirical data for this
massive question the book represents a
colossal achievement but it's so much
more than a mere survey it truly is the
gold standard of economic history of the
ancient Greek world it lays out the data
and sets out the arguments that will
govern what we think about this crucial
question for at least the next
generation and that's because in the
ongoing struggle in the Academy between
the fetus off and the fod play soul
manages to be both while always
remaining grounded in the evidence at
our disposal he understands the larger
implications and theoretical
underpinnings of the larger argument and
is thereby able to work the data to
achieve spectacular results tonight
gracelynn will speak to us on a question
that is related to the economy and might
even be of direct relevance to modern
economic and social problems being faced
by what were the former Greek and Roman
empires how could that be you may ask
yourselves well if you read the New York
Times this morning the editorial section
included in editorial by bit base event
Guinea from the Corriere della Sera who
says that re settling immigrants to
Italy should be done using the ancient
Roman techniques of resettling veterans
on century ated land he writes an entire
article about this this is actually
directly relevant to what we're going to
hear from Grayson when he speaks to us
in a moment on in the land of the
clerics soldiers and their Lots from
Athens to Alexandria I for one would not
be surprised at all if clay stone was
had enough foresight to have foreseen
not just that article but the methods
for resettling soldiers on land in such
a way that he's going to solve all the
problems that Western Europe and
particularly Italy are now facing with a
massive wave of new immigrants but we'll
soon find out let's invite professor
place on to the stage with a round of
applause
well to start with Thank You Noel for
this so nice introduction and hope you
won't be disappointed now but have to
say well it's a great privilege to
deliver this prestigious lecture before
this distinguished audience tonight and
it deeply appreciate this honor first
I'd like to thank the Department of
classics at Yale University for this
invitation but beyond institutions there
are men and women and thus first of all
call Sofia mostov chef whose request is
that the origin of this lecture please
allow me also to thank personally kirk
freudenberg the chair of dept classics
have a pleasure to meet again here at
Yale let me also thank my friends no
Lansky and remaining I suspect that it
is they're interested in economic
straight as justify this invitation of
today and thank you for thinking of
adding my name the list of the
distinguished scholars who have
delivered this lecture in the previous
years finally let me also extend my
special and warm thanks to the friends
and colleagues well accepted to join us
for today and tomorrow's discussion the
highly vana which are a soft serve or
Michael of stuff such as we say was the
perfect classical scholar in one single
person were United the talents of a most
distinguished specialist ancient Greek
and Latin literature epigraphy /
pureology it was also committed our
colleges and excavations director
illustrated by his famous work at dura
Europos but it'll also deep interest in
social and economic history as proof of
his two volumes the social and economic
history of the Roman Empire and a social
nakoma history of the Hellenistic world
what when a is decisive in his work is
deliberate will to produce not only in
comic history of the
ancient world but also to base it on
textual and architect ence this remains
the deep or agility of his work but as
you will soon discover we'll meet again
Russ after in our journey in cleric land
now let me justify the choice of today's
lecture I'm not fully sure that this
young man really was a cleric that is to
say a man in possession of a claris a
landlord this full-length portray was
painting on a steely from the necropolis
of Sidon in today's Lebanon a series of
similar paintings theories can be seen
at Istanbul article museum rather than a
cleric he might well have been a
mercenary in the service of a
Hellenistic King Nikolaus second I
believed that the Sidon Stevie's which
should be dated to the mid-second
century BCE and that there they portray
tell em Ike rather than saluki soldiers
in any case this is most religious tale
steely of a mercenary soldier than that
of a cleric however which should say
immediately that when they were
mobilized to go to war the weapons of
their clerics in all likelihood must
have been very similar to those of the
mercenaries so what are the weapons of
the clerics were this won't be our topic
of tonight but rather their properties
their rights and duties at the starting
point I should perhaps explain the
reason of this inquiry and what
motivated it I met the clerics while
analyzing the question of property
rights in the ancient Greek world indeed
it's a bad basic premise of new
institutional economics that well
defined property rights are precondition
for economic growth economy grows their
words in the ancient world the famous
crafts of Anthony Parker of the number
of shipwrecks in the middle area help us
to visualize this growth also our recent
more recent collaboration by Andy Wilson
but what were the legal conditions of
this growth in that last notice view
the establishment of actual private
property right was one of the major and
original factors that explain growth in
England and more generally in Western
Europe in the medieval and early modern
period my delegation was to examine what
was the situation that prevail in
ancient Greece was it in society where
property rights were perfectly
established and if this was the case can
we say that these property rights also
proved to be a major factor for growth
for almond alcuin with our all dem suits
is the author of the first understanding
analyzes on the topic the definition of
property rights is threefold the
exclusive authority to determine how a
resource is used for instance right to
till land or leave it follow the
exclusive right to the services of the
resource Princeton the right to benefit
from the crop of a landlord and the
right delegate wrentham or sell any
portion of the right spot exchange or
gift which includes all of the right to
transfer it to the person of one's
choice to a son or daughter etc I would
like to stress the role of exclusivity
in audience definition a notion to which
will have to come back the establishment
of property rights suppose is also
inevitably in one form or the other the
existence of a state following Hannah
Arendt we all know that too well that
human rights with other states to
enforce them are pure fiction even
though the state itself can sometimes
become a threat to human rights on this
point with this Russian experience or a
staff who certainly have agreed with
parents and her German experience indeed
if we talk of property rights we must
also talk of the role of the state let
us consider one moment what the European
Convention of Human Rights says a
property rights it first proclaims the
universal and natural character property
rights every natural legal persons
entitled to peaceful enjoyment with
possession no one shall be deprived of
his possessions but immediately as if by
necessity it formulates possible
limitations no one's a very private is
position except in the public interest
and subject to the conditions provided
for by law and the second item adds two
preceding provisions shall not however
in any way impair the right of a state
to enforce such slobs that's deemed
necessary to control the user property
in accordance with the general interest
but as you remember the exclusive use of
property was the first condition in
alkenes definition we like to start a
cache Ristic debate on the question what
remains clear in the European Convention
is that the principle of private
property comes first a property rights
in ancient Greece seemed to meet
perfectly with three definitions of
alchy on the exclusive authority to
determine how resources used well any
Athenian for instance could decide to
tell his land or leave it follow as I
said exclusive right to the service of
the resource and indeed the Athenian
could perfectly do what he wanted with
scrub to sell it to eat the crop or
whatever the point the right to delegate
rent or sell any portion the rights
indeed the same Athenian could for
instance lease is very importantly
seller gave his property to anyone a
waste as well as transfer it to his sons
or any clothes members family members
only specific legal obligations for
indeed we must observe that there was
one was that he was not allowed to sell
his landed property to a final four only
the citizens couldn't have access to
landed property characteristics of
private property in classical violence
degrees in Athens and other similar
cities seem to be almost identical to
ours we are in a world of exclusive
rights despite the inevitable services
and caveats I've talked about this is a
very close to Aristotle's definition in
a rhetoric 157 ownership may be defined
as the right of alienation or not by
which I mean giving the property away or
selling it but where the ancient Greek
cities or kingdoms a world where
property rights can be hard only in
terms of exclusive rights I think that
the answer should be no and this brings
us
to the question of the clouds my query
is consisted in examining whether as
compared to those of the citizens in a
framework of the city the possibly
limited property rights of the clerics
were a distance in type de sensitive for
growth or not interestingly temp sets
has investigated a notion of property
rights in terms of externalities an
externality can be defined as the
unintended consequence on any parties of
the use of the property externalities
can be negative the best example being
that of pollution where negative effects
of the activity of an enterprise impact
the general public or positive like with
the creation of a network based on the
individual use of cell phones in a case
of Clara key where the externality that
might have negatively impacted the
activity of the clerics embers in the
end negatively impacted growth but first
what was at stake with a notion of Clara
key and why was there a specific
definition of Clara cake property in the
ancient Greek world most of the time the
investigation of clerics in Clara
property has been X mine in in a
specific context which perfectly
legitimate the Athenian Empire or the
Talmud Kingdom what I would like to
stress today is that we need a more
comprehensive definition of Clara key
that justify the existence of a common
legal framework both for cities and
kingdoms we need a basic definition to
start from let's come back to our
previous discussion and property rights
we have seen that the state is an
essential factor for existence of
property rights for only the state is
able to enforce them the existence of
the status of cleric or similar statuses
in cultures other than agriculture is
the consequence of a situation where the
state not only performs its role of
state but is also the owner of the land
insofar as the land is of no value
unless it is still by someone it is
necessary to define a special status or
the tenant of this land this is what the
Greeks
Claire Lucas cleric the one who holds
the Clowers the landlord a cleric
receive the land to tell him to exploit
and in Palo he had to perform as a
number of task I must submitted certain
number of taxes and other constraints
the state only in the land could be a
city or a king as we will see although
of course every time with so to speak
specific contracts the same definition
applies to city and kingdom both in the
classical n in the elastic period what
I'd like to demonstrate at least it's
now time to move from general definition
to the real world real world will be
Adams for the cleric ease of city-states
those of Athens of the best known we
shall start our journey with Salamis
because in all likelihood Salamis the
island of Salamis was the oldest
Athenian cleric II perhaps also because
it provides us crucial information on
the status of the Athenian Clara keys
why did you seem necessary to settle
clerics that's to say military colonists
in Salamis the island was very closed
Attica and second equation into atheon
territory might seem to be perfectly
logical yet this was never the case even
in the late hellenistic period or Roman
pure why was it so in a more distant
part past the territory of Marathon and
a tetra police to the northeast of
Attica I've been incorporating into
attic territory this has been the case
even more recently industry of the
territory of a loser's so close to
Salamis and also conquered from the
megarians statistic city to the west
megara it's possible that the insularity
added some foreign character to Salamis
which made it of it a territory that was
desirable to annex but not to
incorporate into the Athenian territory
margarita Geoffrey de has insisted on
the fact that for the Athenians Salamis
was a territory beyond the sea just like
many cities located on islands at the
pariah a continental territory beyond
the sea
however the specific difference seems to
be that not only salamis was conquered
by the Athenians but that the athlean
settlers replaced the previous
landholders this is what I will try to
demonstrate right now what led to this
situation and we were these land holders
previous landholders since at least the
7th century BCE Salamis was a contested
territory between Megara and Athens
Plutarch in his life of Solon tells the
famous story of the despair of the
Athenians of the defeat that suffered
from the megarians in their wars over
the control of Salamis so much so that
in Athens and the pain of death it was
forbidden to anything to mention again
the case of Salamis was so painful and
of a possible new war against the
megarians but pretending to be a full
salon managed to rally his fellow
citizens to opening a new war in this
new war and under the leadership of
solid the Athenians we will if we accept
Plutarch story at face value this
victorious war would have been fought at
the end of the 7th century or rather
perhaps in the early decades of the 6th
century BCE you have the text in your
handout number two maybe it's also for
you to read later but well if you like
you can have a look to the handouts I
will mention at the time protect that
are in there in the handouts every time
I saw the way sollen managed to cocos
Salamis Plutarch's narrative as many
colorful details and provide several
versions of their conquest but the way
Plutarch in paragraph paragraph nine of
the life of Solon refers to the Megerian
is interesting tus insula mini mega
raised the megarians in Sullivan's this
is ignatian equals the formula by which
the Athenian clerics in Salamis later
defined themselves at nao no demos or
insula meany the Athenian people in
Salamis is it a retransmit of illusion
that leads Plutarch imagina contingents
of Nigerian settlers and Salamis similar
to the later contingent
other thing in settlers in the island
one might be tempted to think so if
another sources poze Nia's did not refer
also to contingent for me guardians in
Salamis pezzini's this is your handout
number three might even directly Lou to
me current clerics in the island but the
megarians say a quote but the Megerian
said that exiles from themselves with
the call Tory client's reach the clerics
in Salah miss Clara coos protein I
salomina and betray the island to the
Athenians I don't see how these clerics
couldn't be nothing else than macaron
clerics again if we take this at face
value the text brings forward one
crucial piece of information if we have
to transpose ainias this is in terms of
chronology of very first reference to
clerics in any city or kingdom this fits
well also with the image provided by
Plutarch a very Gary occupation by
military settlers it could also well
explain following decree of the city the
promise that solemn could make to the
volunteers who followed him in the
conquest of the island it's all on
paragraph 9 again then it took 518
volunteers a decree having me made that
these should be in possession of the
settlement if they took it it is clear
that the formula curious a 92 pollito
matos would fit perfectly well with a
body of clerics which settle in Salamis
theand is that and move from then on who
become the ruling power in the island in
that case we have every reason to
believe that the lands given to these
Athenian clerics would those be
previously occupied by the Megerian
settlers the definition of clerics might
be an electron ism but the installation
of Athenian military settlers in
replacement of major n ones could make
of excess the healing kuraki with us
take back to the end of the seventh of
the univ sixth century BCE thus both
Plutarch and Solon refer to in Pezzini
as refer to McGary ins in Salamis only
and we have no trace of authentic
inhabitants of Salamis despite the
currently prevailing views but following
the excellent analyzes mother Taylor on
the topic cannot be proved in the
classical interesting period that's to
say in the Athenian period there were
not two categories of inhabitants in
Salamis won't be informed the death in
clerics and identified by their dematic
the other one descendants of the former
inhabitants would be second-class
Athenian citizen the fact that the theme
settlers replaced the garyun settlers
provides the best possible solution for
the Enigma also of the origin of the
famous gay nose of the Salah minions
with those who are familiar with
Athenian history is a big mystery with
the gainers of the Salah minions the
gala astana minions the religious
association were skulls are linked to
Salamis but were active in Athens in the
classical and the beginning of the
istick period since the publication of
two crucial decrees of the gay nose by
William Scott Ferguson in 1938 there's
been constant debate on the question the
origin of the salami nians most colors
like Ferguson himself believed that the
link with Salamis was a pure fiction the
solemn occasion attend were completed
fission fictional league with Salamis a
minority of scholars think that believe
that at the time of the Athenian
takeover was a swap of population
between the Salah minions and the
Athenian clerics doesn't pay very well
if you want to let's say to have
friendly relations with people who expel
them from their home I think that the
explanation i would suggest would be
more economy after being expelled by the
megarians first in the seventh century
the Salah minions took refuge in Athens
where they were admitted into the
citizen body never to return the Salamis
however they kept the memory of origin
in CT origin the chaos of illuminance
the scenario expects well the difference
between the two trap a list of Marathon
elusive and Salamis the first two
territories was absorbed on block and
their inhabitants were incorporated into
the citizen body Salamis was a different
case it was a product the common
conquest of the Athenian
the new territory was void of its
inhabitants previous inhabitants it was
Athens as a state which was its owner
which implied for the new settlers to
establish the status that could not be
that of an ordinary property within the
borders of the Atheneum state in the 5th
century the Athenians within a framework
with a Empire at the choice between two
forms of legal status for their
settlements in the territories that had
conquered a first one was autonomy and
the loss of citizenship in Athens the
other one was Clara key who have good
reason to believe that from the start
salamis was Clara key an inscription of
the end of the 6th century ig1 cube 1
provides us crucial information on the
status of the clerics at Salamis the
control of Athens over Salamis
materialized and informal settlements of
Athenians we're probably defined as
clerics to a very fortunate of this
inscription which defines the status of
the clerics is the IG in the series of
the inscription of Attica is the first
document so the oldest we have oldest
public document on stone we have four
four four events so um the control of
Athens over Salamis materialized in the
form of the settlement of Athenians
we'll probably defined as clerics
although unfortunately you see the state
of her the stone largely broken there's
a new fragment that should be added to
the right so the world clericus it's on
your handout but well here I just
simplified the word Clara Cruz has to be
restored at the end of line one but it
is quite possible in fact that it was
your hand out number two actually um in
fact an inscription from Lemnos this
time and other Clara
key of the fourth century one century
later refers to gay so the land Paris I
demodulated but you have in refers to
Salamis so it's very well may suggest
that there was some connection between
clarity and salaries in that service way
indeed already a clarity in the return
of the 6th century we'll come back to
this text later so the steams the
statute of Salamis defines the condition
at which the clerics could dwell in the
island it established at least full
series of regulations this is broken but
the beginning we have the first Clause
line on 3 provides the clerics would
reside at Salamis under proviso that
they pay taxes at Athens and perform
military service second clothes provides
the property of the clerics cannot be
leased and that if it is both the lessor
and the less seed will be fine the third
clothes provides details although
military duties of the clerics that you
provide own weapons although the text is
mutilated it provides us crucial
information to make sense of the status
of cleric the first and third clothes
mentioned specific military duties and
the specific military organization
although again the detail is not fully
clear sister fish is to link the status
of cleric to military duties a
characteristic that too we meet again in
other frameworks for instance in the
elastic kingdoms the first Clause also
underscores the payment of taxes at
Athens which implies a lack of autonomy
of the settlements and speaks in favor
of a cleric rather than colonial status
the Salamis we don't know that we do not
know the detail of the taxes that had to
be paid but for the other islands of the
wood are defined as Clara keys in the
fourth
bc we have a famous law of 374 373 BCE
and it establishes that the Athenians
levied toward a cocktail that is attacks
in kind of 112 or eight dot thirty-three
percent on the grain produced in the
islands of Imbros Lemnos and secures
well why is it so important in fact
Lemnos above all and imbrose produce a
huge quantity of grain the amount of
production of grain of these two small
islands was the equivalent of the whole
production of Attica and so this taxing
kind worth of special significance for
the Athenians we do not know if any
similar tax in kind livid in Attica
itself this was a specific tax levied on
the clerics which could be justified by
the fact that these territories have
been the common conquest of the
Athenians which in turn justified the
payment the clothes on renting and
Salinas is also interesting insofar as
it is echoed in documents relating to
Athenian cleric is this is in your house
number number six but you have it on the
screen also this is a regulation to the
clarity of Lemnos we have already seen
this text but there's also one line
which is important for us there is no
possibility to lease is exactly what we
had also in the insula means with the
exception of just like also there was an
exception in Salamis so you see the two
text should be studied in relation with
one another um enough with Athens let's
move on still in the Classical period
but let's go to a kingdom this time this
let's go to Macedon um our first stop
will be at
sandrail in halkidiki northern Greece
Cassandra was a new city founded by
Cassandra's in 316 BCE Cassandra's rule
Macedon from 319 onwards after the death
of his father a rule macedon until his
own death in 298 cassandra after which
he founded was located on the site of
the former personal Greek city of 40
daya the region had been completely
remodeled by the Macedonian conquest in
parallel with Salamis if you like
completely remodeled by the Abyssinian
conquest in 3 48 BCE King Philip of
Macedon famously destroyed all enters
and the cartesian league is a crucial
event in order to make sense of the text
we have at our disposal for the region
and which refer to statute of the land
an inscription coming from Cassandra
that cannot predate for your sex because
it's mentioned Cassandra's as a king and
he proclaimed in cell 14 in 306 refers
to the nation's made by this king this
is your handout number 7 but you have
most of it the text here and the
translation that followed so the text
reads cassandra is king of the
macedonians kept to purdy Carson of coin
toss the estate of the format in the
former territory of sinners and their
stated purposes both of which is
Grandfather polemic rattus received as
clear us and also the estate which is
other received as a clear us in the time
of Philip in the same terms as those on
which Philip gave them as a criminal
possession both they and their
descendants having the full right
possess an exchange on and alienate them
being the son of conus a companion of
Alexander very famous convenient
Alexander fought east pedi cast belong
to the elite of the elite of the
Macedonians the difficulty of the text
which are generated enormous discussion
is the apparent contradiction in terms
between possession and gift we see that
originally two estates were given by
Philip to Polly more clutters but the
cast is Grandfather inevitably the gifts
did back to between 348 date of the
destruction of all enters in 336 the
data the deaths of Philip the second the
third estate was given two corners pas
de casas father and again my fill of a
second so before 336 again it's easy to
see that the estates passed from the
grandfather to the Sun and then to the
grandson / decals but then why was it
necessary for Cassandra's to seemingly
give again this stage this is kind of
hard ox there if a land belongs to me I
don't ask you to give it again that's
the mystery of this step even so even
more if we look to the end of the text
where this time it's an estate that
purdy cast himself as acquired that is
given to him and also their state has
Sparta loss which purdy Casper chased
all silver from taleen ayahs kassandra's
gives this also the price patrimonial
possession so that he is a sum of the
full right to possess etcetra etcetra so
the controversy on the meaning of these
donations have been lasting for more
than a century more recently a full of
consensus seems to listen established
itself that Cassandra's donations were
purely a product of circumstances the US
military's ads or below suggests that
the inscription and stone of Proteus
privileges and also the nations were
only motivated by the transfer of the
estate to the civic territory of
Cassandra and at perdicas at full and
exclusive right on these estates
interestingly this solution had been
rejected by Rostov safe in 1910 more
recently in 2011 in a most valuable
article luccia chris kohler suggest that
the most having a casual reason like
conflicts between the family
or dispute over ownership that without
motivating the reiteration of the
donation I believe and with due respect
to the extra knee scholars that are at
miltos adopt laws and lucha Chris Cole I
think these solutions failed to convince
me at least in the question Cassandra
said donation must be addressed I think
in a global framework of the status of
Clara quick land in fact there is no
contradiction at all between the right
of possession including that of
transferring the property in selling it
and the superior right of the king the
states of purdy cast never left the
kingsland the call of a city k the
Egyptian papyri relating to the stages
of the clerics bring full confirmation
of its point before moving to Egypt let
us consider the case of ski topolice
today Betsy on in northern Israel an
inscription which is one of the jewels
of the Museum of Jerusalem the stream
coming from the city offers a striking
parallel with that of Cassandra the
excerpt I provide here is a memorandum
are written were certain ptolemaeus was
no less than the Strategos and great
priest for the region this year and out
number 8 ptolemaeus send this memorandum
to king Antiochus the third well just
after the crushing defeat of claiming
defeat at pan Yan in 200 BCE which
allowed Antiochus the third to take
control of southern Syria ptolemaeus was
obviously one of these administrators
will change side and were status and
privileges were confirmed by entire cost
the third so Tala Maya's asked the King
to make sure those privileges will be
respected and request King if you so
please to write clearly onerous famous
cellular's the joy kata that as regards
the villages which belong to me as
freehold and patrimonio possession
earn and which you are instructed to
register to my name no one to be
permitted under any pretext to Bill it
himself not to bring in others no to
recreation property not to take away
dependent peasants the famous Lowry
again we find seemingly the same
contradiction with villages that are
inked SI guy in Patrick oyes is the way
I translate as freehold and patrimonial
possession and the fact that the King
had to confirm this donation by
extracting to reduced them to tell him I
us translation interpretation of this
passage has been the object of many
debates again most colors are considered
they were in fact three categories of
estates those that werent SI those that
were in battery course and finally the
village villages that were ascribed by
the king blue chacras colo as shown
recently that the religious mkasi and
those in Patrick eyes phone acting one
and single the same category but mapping
one should go even one step further and
consider they're not two categories and
the st. Patrick wash and those that were
assigned by the king but one only we
have only one series of villages and
that was what was about that the King
has confirmed the possession of these
estates or villages in this case that
were empty say camp at a cost and they
were instructed to register them of
course when there was to take over by
entire cost the third this had to be
done because it was the new king in the
land so once again the estate never left
the Kings land to simply transferred
from the ptolemies to the silicate the
superior property of the king is not at
stake finally within our journey in
Egypt the documents from Ptolemaic Egypt
studied about Dorothy Thompson to
Manning and very recently in a great
book of crystal fish above may all mean
society in Ptolemaic Egypt prove that
the series of specific
rules applied to clarity plan the cleric
old military services and in certain
number of specific taxes if he died
without a song the claris came back to
the bustle corn the royal treasury this
is what we see in a famous papyrus of
238 BCE is in your handout from a 9 so
read the color remember stood below have
died therefore take their clear oil for
the royal treasury and Bubastis the core
of ap- see turkish son of so-and-so
captain at the organist of the core of
Lacan macaws son of captain etc the list
of those people who have died and the
the state has to take care of their
peril another pepper pires peppers lil
14 of 217 bc it's indeed make clear that
if the cleric dies without a son it is
when the cleric dive without a son that
the Claro's would come back to royal
treasury otherwise we can suppose it is
directly inherited by the assault this
proves once and for all to my opinion
that if the cleric could possess the
land he was never the superior owner at
least in this period in egypt the text
of cassandra and other early macedonian
tax Fotopoulos and tala make egypt
present the same legal structure the
last castle really should not invoke a
special a doc reason to make sense of
the new donation of Cassandras the very
nature of klaris given in patrick costs
but recourse to / de cassis grandfather
and father is sufficient reason to make
sense of the new donation by Cassandra
there is however difference that remains
difficult to justify apparently between
the mission of cash and ross and the
attribution of clarence Alamut kingdom
for the talmud clerics to control a
possible retribution took place at the
death of the cleric which is not the
case at Cassandra
how can we make sense of this difference
of course a legal conflict on the
ownership is always possible I don't
deny that but perhaps is better I
potus's to make sense the specific
timing of the donation between 310 date
of the death Alexander the fourth
assassinated by Cassandra's himself and
three years six there was no more King
in Macedon it's only in 306 when
kassandra's takes a royal title like the
other dieter key that the concessional
gap is filled I think that might well
justify the dude in the nation by
kassandra's whereas new king solemnly
confirmed and after the again consumer
gap confirm the donations of his
predecessors we find us so this is why
this exception are in some way but we
find the same situation as catalysts
with a new king this time by conquest
Antiochus that they'll confirm to the
nation of the Ptolemies to tally matters
therefore the information brought
forward by the Cassandra a dossier is
crucial term opinion it proved that
already in second half of the fourth
century and if even before exams
conquest of Asia the status of cleric
was well defined in Macedon on this
point like also many others it is thus
clear that the clerical system came to
Asia with the Macedonian conquerors
others argued that this will be my
conclusion that the legal status known
as claro kia is linked to a specific
situation when a state a city or king
while remaining the owner of the land
allocates land lots of this land to
settlers in exchange of the rights to
hedge repossession including the right
to sell it Oh specific duties first of
all military service but also specific
taxes and other duties beyond this
common framework the clarity contracts
if I dare say they've heard from one
another there's no reason to believe
that in the detail the rules that
applied to the Athenian clerics will
necessarily the same as though that
applied to clerics in the message on
in tradition in macedon or indiana state
kingdoms an Athenian cleric could not
leave his land but on this point I I
don't know simply it remains to be
proved that the same replied to
messaging the clerics only the son of
them Talia cleric could inherit his
father's claris at least in the third
century in Egypt but usually needs to be
proved that the same replied in the
Athenian Clarice I think the timing we
just don't know finally we should come
back to the question asked at the
beginning of this lecture where the
negative externalities that impacted the
clerics possession of the land and it
would have been disincentive to invest
his time and activity in the Clara
suppose that distance our cleric where
did he think of his Clara's we have good
reason to answer in the negative and
first of all because of the
transferability of the Clara's if the
donation was made in patrimony this was
a strong incentive for him to take Clara
seriously right you can transfer that to
your son or descendant etc but with some
caveats however the great Macedonian
nobleman we receive donations at the
beginning of the third century BC in
Macedon or in Asia Minor they receive
donation from the elastic kings do their
best to transfer the estates to the
territory of a city this is a clue that
the status of civic clan remain more
attractive more variable than that of
the clear okiya or other status in the
Kings land the reason was certainly that
taxes I suspect were higher in a coral
Basilica when there was such as a cleric
in Egypt in the 2nd century BCE several
papyri show that the obstacles or the
transferability of the Clara's to a
daughter seemed to disappear there are
people who know much better than I do
the the Egyptian dossier but that's this
dissent in other evolutions like
exemption of specific taxes are also
reckon
ninja in the lingerie the trend was just
to a standardization of property rights
I mean my best to transform stitch rags
in two o'clock whether I've succeeded is
not up to me to say thank you for
attention
you